mayors across the country are asking
Washington to take control or take
action rather on gun control Adriana
Diaz has interviewed four mayor's from
different political parties whose cities
have been shaken by gun violence there's
Dayton Ohio mayor nan Whaley parkland
Florida mayor Christine hon Chomsky
Virginia Beach Mayor Bobbie Dyer and
Washington DC Mayor Muriel Bowser they
want to see bipartisan gun safety
legislation following the mass shootings
in Dayton and El Paso I think we're
getting to a place where it has happened
to so many places to so many people that
there is finally a tipping point on it
this fear of the gun makers and the gun
lobby is changing and so I think there's
real opportunity for real bipartisanship
the key for us is to make sure that we
bring everybody to the table to build
those positive bridges and start
trusting each other we have to start
communicating with each other we have to
do more active listening to find out you
know what's going on
you know we can't serve as mayors as a
focus group of one after parkland our
families got together and started stand
with parkland and our families are on
every end of the political spectrum but
they came together to work on issues
that they felt there could be
compromised they've paid the ultimate
price for this and they know what it
means if we don't figure out a way to
stop these mass shootings and you can
see more of Adriana's conversation with
all four mayors tomorrow on CBS this
morning
important to that conversation